[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde
est très heureuse d'être avec vous donc
questionnaire philosophe Chantal Duga
artiste architecte
donc voilà on est effectivement
le jour de la Toussaint 1er novembre
1900 2023 on n'a pas remonté le temps et
voilà on est au cimetière de Bron et
effectivement jour de la Toussaint les
personnes amènent des fleurs pour venir
visiter leur défunt il y a un petit
atelier dans un coin du cimetière
où il y a quelques écailles en inox les
gens peuvent laisser un message au
défunt et nous
le climat et moi-même nous sommes là
pour prendre intercepter ces messages et
les graver sur l'inox vous laissez cette
notion de passage entre la vie et la
mort
donc on a essayé de choisir cette
exemple pour parler comment on peut agir
dans l'ombre qui est quelque part l'être
et l'encre et aussi pour parler de ce
vis-à-vis et la vie et la mort qui se
regarde face à face
comme
l'explique
qu'on apprécie les deux effectivement il
y a cette histoire de du bitwin et de in
between donc le bitwin c'est de quel en
face de l'autre avec le front qui passe
d'un côté à l'autre et puis au centre il
y a une
between c'est l'eau bon mouvement donc
voilà on est dans ce face-à-face et avec
l'angle qui est en mouvement qui a envie
très important puisque à ce moment on
peut partager c'est quoi à quel point
partir de ces oeuvres ce qui apparaît
c'est l'attachement entre les êtres
humains c'est-à-dire que lorsque
quelqu'un va disparaître sa présence
continue à être habité la demande le
monde est habité par tous ceux qui nous
ont précédés et en fait il y a une
grande chaîne de
alors c'est aussi voir à quel point dans
ce devenir dans ce qui est en train de
cette mise en mouvement du monde c'est
quelle est la place on va faire en tant
qu'humanité à tout ce qui est autre
chose que les humains et donc c'est la
place du vivant qui va retrouver aussi
de bien je pense et qui nique l'appareil
comme étant un des points extrêmement
importants dans notre époque
c'est-à-dire ce 21ème siècle nous
tournant du vivant ou l'humain reprend
sa place au milieu du végétal au milieu
de la des animaux de toutes les formes
en fait de vie qui sont qui lui ont
permis en fait d'énerver donc cette
dimension là de du vivant elle va avec
aussi cette prise en considération du
fait que les humains les êtres humains
sont des êtres de culture et de nature
les deux sont indissociables et que ce
mouvement-là portait en particulier par
tout un mouvement éco-féministe
va mettre l'accent sur le fait que on
n'est pas obligé de se situer simplement
en maître dominateur de toutes les
formes de vie sur terre mais que au
contraire on appartient en fait il y a
un tissage autour de toutes ces formes
de vie qui permettent que chacune ait
lieu donc ce mouvement des communistes
finalement attire l'attention sur
l'éthique du Caire le prendre soin
c'est-à-dire le fait d'être attentionné
à soi aux autres aux autres espèces aux
autres formes de vie
et donc c'est d'un seul coup d'autres
questions qui sont étudiées prises en
considération sur l'empathie c'est vrai
qu'à partir de ce qu'on voit écrire dans
ce qui est écrit dans ces justement donc
ces écailles on voit à quel point il y a
de l'attachement aux êtres comment
quelque chose de très affectif bâtissait
aussi tous ces liens il y a
l'intelligence mais aussi il y a toutes
ces tous ces liens qui relient les êtres
des uns aux autres donc parmi les
questions que l'on se pose vis-à-vis des
interactions et de tous ces liens ces
dynamiques de liens c'est le qu'est-ce
qui va permettre de faire tenir ensemble
finalement toute cette communauté
vivante à cette fameuse communauté biote
quand on parle souvent
et comment va faire communauté on sait à
quel point depuis finalement depuis la
nuit des temps on peut dire quelque part
les humains cherchent des moyens pour
faire tenir ensemble leur société leur
communauté communauté de vie et à surgit
par exemple on peut dire à la suite
aussi de tous les cataclysmes du XXe
siècle des guerres finalement
mondialisées cette idée que il y avait
par exemple avec Anna rent elle est
partie de l'idée de l'importance de la
table démocratique cette idée qu'il y a
un espace entre les humains un espace
politique a inventé qui sera basée sur
la délibération sur le partage des
actions sur le partage de la mémoire
aussi de tout ce qui a été produit au
fil du temps et que c'est cette
[Musique]
de devenir dans le mouvement comment
s'adapter et comment d'une certaine
manière trouver le moyen de continuer à
être dans une humanité des humanités
écosites
c'est-à-dire où en fait toutes les
formes de vie vont pouvoir avancer
ensemble sans continuer
à finalement surconsommer détruire tout
ce qui finalement a été produit au fil
au fil des millénaires donc cette
attention se prendre soin de bien une
nouvelle forme de boussole commune une
certaine manière mais qu'elle va être
finalement la boussole individuelle des
uns et des autres comment chacun va
pouvoir faire du sol dans un monde qui
est un monde aujourd'hui qui est notre
monde toute fédération confondue donc le
trouble vous parle Donnard haway
le fait de ne pas savoir quelle est la
bonne direction à prendre pour
finalement faire le moins mal possible
ou le faire le mieux possible comment
Bruxelles on est en train de voir à quel
point la puissance humaine la puissance
de transformation des milieux habités a
été telle que elle a aussi détruit les
beaucoup de ressources et elle on
apprend on prend la mesure on a pris
conscience de façon collective du fait
que nous sommes dans une planète très
fragile très limitée aux ressources très
limitées et donc il faut réinventer ces
boussole le boussole à titre individuel
et à titre collectif donc c'est pour
nous aussi quelque chose qui nous
intéressait de voir dans quelle mesure
la question de l'encre nous amène à
réinterroger comment s'orienter pour
pouvoir avancer ensemble dans l'horizon
qui est tout à fait avenir et inconnu
certaine manière on sait et on sait à
quel point tout ce qui nous a précédé va
nous nourrir comment cela se ressource à
partir de cette déjà eu lieu mais aussi
comment va se ressourcer à partir de ce
qu'on va être capable d'inventer et de
créer ensemble au fur et à mesure
voilà et pour continuer toujours dans ce
proposition qu'on a souhaité vous
présenter par rapport à ce travail
d'oeuvre collective donc ça c'était la
première étape chacun écrivait un
message laisser un message et pensez
prendre ce message elle posait sur sur
une tombe de leur défunt et on leur a
dit non c'est pas l'idée l'idée c'est
mettre tous ces messages ensemble
570 c'est pas des moindres ensemble
comme un tumulus de lumière donc
tumuluses de lumière c'est vraiment un
peu cette représentation de la table cet
élément qui rassemble c'est une sorte de
forme architecturale qui ancestrale qui
ramène cet aspect de cimetière de forme
et
d'arrondit de double peau à la terre et
qui renvoie la lumière et qui joue entre
les messages et la lumière donc
effectivement on a on pense dans une
notion d'habiter le trouble en prenant
la citation de Dana ah ouais par rapport
à cette approche ou comme l'a énoncé
Chris
l'école la boussole les cousus chics
nous oblige être dans la mobilité en
architecture tout ce qu'on fait comme
artefact et dans l'immobilité et
aujourd'hui ce regard qu'on doit avoir
sur la vie sur le vivant mais dans une
attitude je dirais organique et donc
effectivement les causes la notion
d'appliquer le trouble nous oblige être
en mouvement chercher nos repères
chercher l'axe mais l'axe n'est jamais
le même il bouge il bouge avec le temps
il bouge avec la lumière il bouge avec
avec le contexte etc etc donc
effectivement cette approche qu'on a de
cet être dans l'encre habiter l'antre
comme c'est un sujet qui est assez
passionnant de Christiane sur la
question d'habiter ça nous conditionne
dans une attitude et peut-être aussi
dans une idée de transmettre puisque
vous êtes pédagogue de le transmettre
auprès de nos étudiants de comment on
peut finalement générer des pédagogies
qui développent cette attitude de
l'encre
basée sur le pouvoir être en fait il y a
un pouvoir être pouvoir être de venir
ensemble ce que dans l'idée
précisément qu'ils ont que l'on sait par
gattari qui était un psychiatre mais qui
s'est développé des méthodes très
alternatives aussi pour accompagner le
pouvoir être des
êtres humains et de la vulnérabilité
humaine et de la souffrance humaine
cette idée que en fait on a maintenant
un nouveau défi collectif comment qui
est
à partir de tous nos attachements à
partir de toutes nos souffrances aussi
parce qu'on voit la tristesse de perdre
des êtres chers c'est comment on arrive
à faire tenir ensemble les dimensions
qui sont sociales environnementales mais
aussi mental l'espace cet espace
intérieur que chacun d'entre nous a qui
va nourrir en fait notre capacité
finalement à devenir ensemble
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un grand défi
dans cette boussole échosophique parce
que c'est pas une réponse c'est au
contraire une voix qui est de dire
ensemble quelle boussole en plus donner
pour faire un monde qui serait plus
attentionné plus empathique plus
respectueuse plus engagés aussi pour
intervenir dans la juste intervention
par rapport au monde dans lequel on est
sans pénaliser les générations à venir
et permettre à tous celles qui sont là
évidemment de ce de se développer donc
cette dimension là
cette idée de boussole ecosophique c'est
pas une réponse c'est plutôt un chemin
qui s'ouvre en horizon parce que
certainement notre notre siècle ce 21e
siècle ce siècle de l'anthropocène qui
voit tous les tous ceux qui a été
finalement tout ce qui pèse finalement
déjà sur des productions
il ouvre un nouvel à nouvelle nouveau
possible de nouveaux mondes qui vont
être basés beaucoup sur la question
justement des liens qui lient les êtres
les uns aux autres comme ça paraît
fortement dont une méduse de lumière
voilà je crois qu'on a terminé merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]